Finally, I want to emphasize again that a key requirement
in mobile web development is optimizing for battery usage. Battery
life in your user's mobile device is an incredibly precious
resource. So I want to call this out as an explicit
goal, even though it's hard to directly measure. The best
way to optimize battery life is, well, to only do work
when you need to. This may seem pretty obvious, but
all the things we've talked about in this lesson are applicable
to this. In fact, network usage, computation, and
rendering are all heavy indicators of battery usage.
But the other APIs we'll talk about later
can also affect this. For example, using the GPS
changes battery usage, as does the camera. One
final comment, there are several tools out there
that will analyze your page for you and
make some suggestions on how to improve your performance.
My personal favorite, of course, is PageSpeed Insights
which is a Google tool that you can
point at any website and it will give
you feedback on your performance. With that, and
the tools you've acquired in this lesson, you're
on your way to designing performant web apps.
In the problem set, we're going to be
going over testing the conference app, with PageSpeed.